There's no point in denying that Harrison
Ford has long been considered the resident
grump of the "Star Wars" ensemble. He's
known to be a bit grouchy towards the
franchise that gave him his first big break
into movie stardom. He's even gone so far
as to repeatedly mention how he wished for
Han Solo to get killed off at some point.
Apparently, he simply doesn't like
playing Han Solo and would prefer to
take on more three-dimensional characters in
the vein of Rick Deckard from "Blade Runner."
But unless you've been vigilant in
reading every scrap of information
you can about Ford and his co-stars on the
sets of the original "Star Wars" movies,
you might not be familiar with a
tidbit dropped by one Mark Hamill
during a 2015 interview about his memories
of working with Harrison Ford on the films.
Before we go on, it's probably a good idea to
point out that Hamill's feelings towards Ford seem
to be uniformly, and mutually, positive. In an
interview with Jake's Takes from February of 2020,
Ford returned the favor by saying something
quite nice about his Jedi comrade-in-arms:
"When I met Mark Hamill, I really
learned how to be cool ... He's just
a really straightforward nice
guy. He's really a sweet guy."
But Hamill has shared at least one "Star Wars"
memory that shows Ford could
be somewhat volatile on set.
In a 2015 interview with Empire, Mark Hamill
shared a funny story about an incident involving
Harrison Ford and Han Solo's iconic spaceship:
"You heard about Harrison taking a saw to the
Millennium Falcon because he got so mad? People
were coming up to me, going, 'You gotta stop
Harrison, he's sawing up the Falcon.' It was
made of wood, and he just took a saw to it."
Hamill didn't share exactly what Ford
was mad about when he decided to make
such unorthodox use of his skills as a carpenter,
but he did share that he was able to
bring things to a peaceful resolution.
"I love Harrison. I got to stop him because
I can make him laugh when he gets really,
really mad. And I had no stake in it. He was with
Carrie, and I was still hanging out with Yoda."
The Yoda reference is a clue that the incident
in question happened during filming of "The
Empire Strikes Back." Fortunately,
Hamill was there to calm Ford down,
and production of what many fans consider
to be the masterpiece of the entire "Star
Wars" saga proceeded to its eventual
creative and commercial success.
Given stories like the one Hamill shared, it'd
be easy to assume Ford is a grump all day,
every day. However, considering his career
has spanned several decades at this point
across numerous different franchises, one has to
assume people enjoy working with him to an extent.
After all, no matter how good of an actor you are,
a bad attitude is a surefire way to sink
any career, no matter what your name is.
Fortunately, it appears Ford knows
when to cut loose and have fun.
In the same Empire interview,
Hamill goes on to tell a story
of how Ford knows when to be silly,
as well. Hamill goes on to relate,
"He's got a wonderfully wacky sense
of [humor]. I'll give you an example.
This disco song that goes, 'More, more, more, how
d'ya like it, how d'ya like it,' remember that?
We used to love really bad pop songs, so
whenever that song would come on I'd run
and turn it on. And he'd come into
my dressing room and start dancing."
You aren't alone if you're having a
difficult time envisioning Harrison
Ford dancing along to disco songs. As it
turns out, there's a good reason for that:
"The minute somebody comes to the door,
he'd stop dead and stand there. 'Yeah,
okay, I'll be down to the set in a
minute.' As soon as the door closes,
it's, 'Get the action going!'
He'd only do it around me."
It sounds as though Ford and
Hamill have a special bond,
and there's a specific image Ford
wants emitted to the general public.
Still, we'd give anything to see that
footage of Ford dancing along to Andrea True.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.